okay right to the point what is
hydroxychloroquine and how does it
relate to coronavirus hydroxychloroquine
is primarily used to treat malaria and
in addition has a second property where
it behaves as an ionophore and ionophore
is a protein or molecule that transports
ions across the cell membrane how do we
notice about hydroxychloroquine a 2014
paper conclusively showed that
hydroxychloroquine shuttled zinc ions
into cancer cells causing them to
undergo apoptosis in the experiment two
conditions were set up where cells were
exposed to zinc with and without
hydroxychloroquine the condition with
zinc but no hydroxychloroquine showed
miniscule concentrations of zinc in the
cells the other condition where
hydroxychloroquine and zinc were both
present showed a significant increase in
the cells this proved that
hydroxychloroquine acted as an anaphor
for zinc this is a scenario where a
medication designed for one use also has
an unexpected secondary use for example
aspirin had an unexpected use for
mitigating heart attacks in 1899 aspirin
was initially used as a mild pain
reliever
it wasn't until 1950 that it was
discovered to reduce clotting in the
blood this was advantageous to use
during heart attacks to increase the
chances of survival by preventing blood
clots with hydroxychloroquine it's
believed the zinc ion inhibits an enzyme
specific to the coronaviruses
replication when corona virus infects a
cell it's RNA genome is released into
the cell cytoplasm the host cell
ribosome then translates a specific RNA
strand into the enzyme our DRP from here
the our DRP enzyme copies the other
coronavirus strands the host cell again
then translates these RNA strands into
more viral proteins these viral proteins
are assembled into new viruses and then
infect other cells in the body it's
believed the our TRP enzyme can be
inhibited by a zinc ion therefore
halting this entire life cycle how do we
know all this is true well we don't know
100% for sure
however a paper from 2010 tested a
different ionophore called pyrethrum
incredibly they tested this on the
Tsarskoe virus that was widespread in
2003
researchers found that as the zinc ion
concentration increased in the cell
there is less viral RNA copies being
made scientists theorized that zinc was
inhibiting our DRP as it's the enzyme
responsible for making copies of viral
RNA there is one caveat though this
concept was tested on the Tsarskoe virus
from 2003 and not the current SARS Cove
2 that we're dealing with right now the
viruses are similar as they're from the
same family but they are not identical
when it comes to medical science
clinical studies with reproducible
results art king as of now clinical
trials are being conducted at unseen
rates to test this and other theories to
stop the virus at this point only time
will tell